[Música]
hola bienvenidos a el debate de france
24 soy santiago lópez gonzález
indecisión esa podría ser la palabra que
define la campaña de cara a las
elecciones presidenciales en costa rica
25 candidatos de todo el espectro
político del país están allí
representados
la intención de voto está disipada y eso
hace pensar en que será necesario ir a
una segunda vuelta para el mes de abril
quien triunfe será llamado a sustituir a
carlos alvarado el presidente de la que
es considerada como la democracia modelo
de américa central para ponernos en
contexto vamos a ver el siguiente
reportaje preparado por la redacción de
france 24 veas
de los 25 candidatos presidenciales 3
son favoritos el candidato de tendencia
más conservadora es fabricio alvarado de
47 años este pastor evangélico se opone
al matrimonio entre parejas del mismo
sexo y al derecho al aborto ya como
candidato en 2018 centró su campaña en
temas sociales esta vez también apuesta
por su programa económico nosotros hemos
planteado en nuestro plan de gobierno el
plan 14-14
es un plan que pues precisamente
pretende reactivar la economía para
generar una disminución al desempleo
para dejar al desempleo en un 6 por
ciento como máximo para finales de
nuestro gobierno en el 2026 frente a el
inet saborio de 61 años exvicepresidenta
en la década del 2000 y miembro del
partido de tendencia neoliberal unidad
social cristiana asegura que quiere
hacer de la lucha contra la corrupción
una prioridad vamos a trabajar muy
fuerte contra la corrupción
vamos a traer muy fuerte contra la
impunidad pero especialmente queremos
poner a costa rica en una línea que le
corresponde y es un país más justo con
más oportunidades más equitativo está
con tercer candidato que fue presidente
de costa rica en la década de 1990 el
socialdemócrata josé maría figueres de
67 años
pero el momento en las encuestas de uno
de los tres favoritos supera el 20% de
la intención de voto y casi la mitad de
los votantes siguen indecisos sin ningún
candidato obtiene el 40 por ciento de
los votos este domingo se organizará una
segunda vuelta del 3 de abril entre los
principales candidatos
ya lo veamos son 25 candidatos muchos
dicen que esta amplia oferta ha
confundido un poco al electorado lo
vamos a analizar algunos minutos con
nuestros analistas invitados pero lejos
de la polémica de campaña de hace cuatro
años en donde hubo un revuelo por el
tema del matrimonio igualitario y
también por la ley de género en esta
oportunidad no hay grandes polémicas al
menos eso parece por lo menos lo que se
fue fuera lo que se ve desde fuera de
las fronteras de costa rica- la
recuperación económica y el tema de los
impuestos son tal vez los temas que más
le están preocupando a los
costarricenses dejando un poco de lado
un tema coyuntural para el mundo entero
que es la pandemia de kobe 19 y también
dejando un poco de lado el tema
ambiental del cual costa rica es
abanderado en la región como se
presentan entonces las campañas de qué
es hablando en el debate electoral
costarricense que quieren los ciudadanos
que ofrecen los candidatos y cuáles son
las prioridades que tiene este país
centroamericano hoy en el debate de
france 24 las indecisas elecciones en
costa rica es nuestro tema para
analizarlo hemos invitado a eugenia
aguirre ellas politóloga e investigadora
del observatorio de la política nacional
de la universidad de costa rica también
en san josé la capital costarricense
está rod sei rosales valladares él es
coordinador del observatorio de la
política nacional de la universidad de
costa rica y también estará con nosotros
para comentar algunos puntos en
particular nuestra corresponsal allí en
este país centroamericano cindy regidor
ustedes ya la conoce por sus habituales
informes desde la ciudad de san josé
ustedes también nuestros televidentes
pueden participar en el debate con sus
comentarios y todas sus preguntas lo
pueden hacer a través de nuestras redes
sociales no se encuentran en facebook en
instagram también en twitter estamos
como france24 bajo ese arroba sant y
luego que es mi cuenta personal
en la etiqueta les recuerdo es numeral
el debate 24 esperamos los comentarios
las preguntas do inició el debate
entonces preguntándole a eugenia la
primera invitada que presenté para el
programa hablando del tema de la
indecisión que fue precisamente la
palabra que puse como para tratar de
poner en contexto lo que están viviendo
los costarricenses hay una gran oferta
de candidatos 25 allí falta de conexión
entre
los candidatos la población una oferta
muy amplia porque se está dando esa
indecisión eugenia
un cordial saludo un gusto estar en el
debate
tiene que iniciar con la discusión
alrededor de como la oferta electoral ya
se probó a través de estudios de opinión
está confundiendo al electorado
particularmente en lo que tiene que ver
con la cantidad de oferta política y la
variedad de la misma es decir un hito
histórico en términos de la opción que
tienen las y los costarricenses de
acudir a las urnas es sushi
concentrada la atención en una quinta
parte de esas candidaturas que ninguna
supera la intención de voto necesaria
para alcanzar la barrera electoral del
40 por ciento de los votos válidamente
emitidos a unos pocos días de las
elecciones los estudios también
demuestran que las personas están a la
espera de los debates televisivos los
diversos espacios televisivos para tomar
una decisión que cada día se postergan
más cercana al día de la elección y
concentra
la intención de voto en estas 5
candidaturas principales
rocha y su opinión sobre esta indecisión
de la que son protagonistas los
costarricenses de cara a estas
elecciones presidenciales
me parece buenas tardes me gusta estar
con el debate me parece que es una
tendencia no es un hecho aislado que se
presenta en esta oportunidad ya en al
menos los dos anteriores procesos
electorales generan presidenciales y
legislativos que había expresado esta
indecisión y está más bien decisión de
última hora y más claramente sucedió en
el 2018 cuando una noticia el mundo
habrá escuchado que fue un
pronunciamiento la corte interamericana
de derechos humanos terminó en las
últimas tres semanas de la campaña
electoral por inclinar la balanza a
favor de dos personas candidatas que
pasaron la segunda ronda sin que las
encuestas de opinión lo hubiesen
detectado con esa claridad y con
suficiente anterioridad me parece que
ahora la verdadera novedad es que la
indecisión está llegando a una semana de
las elecciones de los comicios en un
nivel un cartel visto tenemos más 40%
entre el 40 y el 50 por ciento según los
datos del 7 la universidad de costa rica
que todavía hasta la fecha se siguen
diciendo diciendo indecisos y a mi
juicio sea una esta situación un
fenómeno estadísticamente también
estudiado que es el de la espiral del
silencio cada vez es más sistemática la
manera en cómo las personas ciudadanas
en este país se niegan y algún modo se
avergüenza agradecer también por que
inclinaría su voto oa cual candidatura y
partido político está apoyando
importante esa explicación que usted
hace rod side sobre este tipo de
mentalidad que se está presentando allí
o de idea de los costarricenses de no
decir simplemente por quién van a votar
quiero pasar a preguntarle a cindy
regidor nuestra corresponsal hay en san
josé sobre el pulso en las calles que
dicen los costarricenses ante esta gran
oferta de 25 candidatos en un país
centroamericano con una población que
pasa un poco más allá o tal vez llega a
los 5 millones de habitantes aunque se
comenta allí más allá de la indecisión
que es lo que con lo que hemos iniciado
el debate pero que comenta la gente en
las calles sobre esto 5 candidatos a
esta oferta tan amplia
bueno santiago yo creo que la población
está clara de que debe por lo menos ir
acercándose a seleccionar un grupo más
pequeño de candidatos para luego tomar
la decisión final de a quien entregarle
su voto el domingo 6 de febrero deja al
menos lo que yo sentí en la calle cuando
entrevistamos a ciudadanos en los
mercados en las principales avenidas de
la capital la gente ya tiene más o menos
vistos los perfiles de los candidatos
que están encabezando las encuestas de
intención de votos pero si todavía no se
deciden quién será esa persona a la que
le van a entregar su voto del día
domingo lo que sí es que definitivamente
la población en estos últimos días está
mucho más reflexiva también y creo que
hay una tendencia a ver más a los
partidos los planes de gobierno que
están presentando si tienen también
equipos esos candidatos con los cuales
vayan a lograr cumplir esas promesas y
yo creo que también es importante
destacar el perfil de la persona
indecisa es una gran parte son jóvenes
son eres y son de las provincias
costeras y eso pues habría que ver si es
que los candidatos quizás no están
hablando lo suficiente de esas
poblaciones sobre qué es lo que les
están ofreciendo y pues habría que ver
también cómo va a impactar si finalmente
esta población no se decide a salir a
votar que algo que todavía no se espera
las botas la abstención en este país no
supera el 30 por ciento en las
elecciones anteriores y se espera que
esta ocasión pues también la ciudadanía
se presente a votar pero sí habría que
esperar que esta población pues
finalmente tome una decisión en los
últimos días o inclusive el mismo día de
la elección cuando vaya a las urnas
cindy usted menciona un punto importante
que tengo aquí en mi en mi lista de
temas y es el voto de las mujeres el
voto de los jóvenes van a ser muy
representativos en esta elección lo
dejamos sobre la mesa lo vamos a tratar
en unos minutos quiero cerrar este tema
de los 25 candidatos con eugenia y con
roth 6 preguntándoles a ver costa rica
es un país muy pequeño y eso ya lo hemos
dicho el ejemplo democrático de la
región de américa latina de américa
central pero 25 candidatos tal vez no
sería mejor para evitar un desgaste
electoral y también porque la
infraestructura de la autoridad
electoral de allí ha dicho que esto le
está costando un poco poner en marcha
todo este proceso electoral por la
cantidad de candidatos que hay
porque no está este fenómeno de las
coaliciones porque estos candidatos tal
vez no se unieron entre partidos para
hacer una propuesta conjunta y así
abarcar de pronto un poco un electorado
un poco más amplio eugenia
en el caso de costa rica- santiago bueno
es una pregunta muy importante si hubo
intentos de coaliciones sobre todo de
los sectores que se identifican más como
liberales o asia hacia la derecha del
espectro político sin embargo las reglas
electorales estipuladas en el código
electoral imponen una serie de
requisitos para el establecimiento de
coaliciones que hemos ido valorando
sistemáticamente que
desincentiva en la creación de este tipo
de fórmulas en este sentido además
muchos de los partidos políticos que se
presentan del total de 25-13 son
agrupaciones políticas que nunca habían
participado en un proceso electoral
nacional y que recurrieron a la figura
del partido político ya una figura
conocida o mediática para impulsar sus
aspiraciones entonces en este escenario
además torna aún más confuso a la
ciudadanía porque estamos viendo figuras
con amplio reconocimiento político
asumir nuevas banderas
y les permitan obtener el poder a través
del proceso electoral entonces no sólo
se trata de una oferta amplia sino que
es una oferta que se presenta como
novedosa pero que recurre a figuras que
el electorado costarricense reconoce en
otras agrupaciones rocha y su opinión
sobre ésta nos explicaban el contexto
por lo menos a nivel de leyes porque no
se forman estas coaliciones pero de cara
a esa eventual segunda vuelta que pueda
haber en el mes de abril pueden verse
estas formaciones o coaliciones o
uniones o alianzas como se le quiera
llamar para poder enfrentar de una
manera más fuerte estas candidaturas
para la segunda vuelta que piensa usted
me parece que es absolutamente
indispensable sobre todo para las dos
personas candidatas plantearse el reto
de convencer de persuadir y de
finalmente a una gracias sus filas y las
fuerzas que están hoy gravitando en
torno a las restantes 23 personas y
candidaturas que no van a pasar la
segunda ronda y eso no me parece malo me
parece más bien positivo entre frito
absolutamente indispensable en virtud de
la fragmentación del sistema de partidos
y de las decisiones que muchas de ellas
dependen del trámite la discusión y la
correlación de fuerzas que se dé no al
interno del gobierno y el ejecutivo sino
justamente a través de una asamblea
legislativa que pareciera va a estar
nuevamente bastante fragmentada de modo
que la articulación de decisiones pero
sobre todo de proyectos que resulten
llamativas a esas otras opciones que
quedaron de fuera te viene absolutamente
indispensable y ya estaremos hablando de
alianzas políticas de cara al ejercicio
del gobierno pero acordémonos que no es
lo mismo las alianzas y las
negociaciones que se hacen
para ganar elecciones claras las
alianzas y las negociaciones que se
hacen para gobernar de modo que va a ser
un equilibrio delicado que ahí también
se va a demostrar durante estos dos
meses que sin duda va a haber entre la
primera y la segunda ronda digo sin duda
haber segunda ronda amiwis y desde
lograrlo hemos observado de esa manera
pero me parece que esos dos meses que
hay entre la primera y la segunda ronda
van a ser vital para que la misma
ciudadanía perciba quién de las dos
personas candidatas va a tener mayor
liderazgo para lograr esas
articulaciones que como bien disguste
hasta el mes de agosto que era el plazo
final para realizar coaliciones
electorales no se logró concretar por
distintas razones pero pienso que muchas
de ellas tienen que ver lamentablemente
con vanidades y ambiciones de tipo
personal
que también entra en juego entonces en
este panorama electoral en costa rica
cindy quiero pasar a comentar ahora los
ejes de los temas de las campañas ya
cerraron allí viendo comentarios de
ciudadanos costarricenses en diferentes
medios de comunicación han dicho que
hubo un despliegue de publicidad
grande por lo menos muchas vallas en las
vías en las carreteras costarricenses
muchísima publicidad para mover sus
campañas las propuestas también se
quedaron sobre la mesa y muchos
ciudadanos dicen que no conocen muy bien
que lo que están proponiendo los
candidatos como cerraron las campañas
cuáles son los temas que se están
moviendo y ya vamos a profundizar con
eso ni con root site sobre estos temas
el tema número uno sin duda santiago es
el tema de lo económico cómo
lograr que el país tenga una
reactivación económica ese término se ha
vuelto muy común sobre todo después de
la pandemia cómo lograr traer más empleo
al país cómo lograr este que baje la
pobreza y la pobreza extrema esos son
los temas que mencionan todos los
candidatos sobre todo en sus cierres de
campaña en donde prometen que tienen
el equipo y las ideas correctas para
poder lograr eso hay candidatos que
prometen 200 mil empleos hay algunos que
también están por el tema de ordenar la
casa y eso tiene que ver con un tema de
ordenar o lograr bajar el déficit fiscal
hacer un estado más eficiente lograr
ahorrar dinero no más impuestos hay
varios candidatos que se refieren a esto
no quieren poner más impuestos o al
menos eso es lo que dicen a la
ciudadanía para no
empeorar la situación de la ciudadanía y
creo que también el tema de la
corrupción ha sido muy importante para
la ciudadanía porque en los últimos
meses han estallado varios escándalos de
corrupción en donde han estado
implicadas diferentes instituciones
estatales y yo creo que también el tema
de la educación cómo mejorar el sistema
educativo costarricense y la inseguridad
que la ven pues asociada a un tema de
pobreza yo creo que el tema de la
pandemia santiago de cierta manera así
es que se conversa se discute porque
mucha gente está por un manejo más laxo
de la gestión de la pandemia para que
eso no afecte la economía mientras que
otros sostienen no hay que priorizar el
tema de la salud de que las personas no
se contagien que no mueran más personas
a causa del coronavirus
rops hay su opinión sobre este tema
prioridad en la economía es lo que nos
dice cindy es la prioridad son los temas
que los costarricenses ven como una
necesidad inmediata poner en marcha otra
vez la economía costarricense
qué tan difícil está la situación allí
que tan prioritario debe ser este tema
por en ti por encima del tema de la
salud por ejemplo por el tema de la
pandemia
se notó claramente durante el extendido
año de 2020 así ya van a ser dos años
cuando inició la pandemia y el gobierno
y muchos otros en el mundo y
particularmente en américa latina se vio
la disyuntiva en que priorizar si el
resguardo a la salud o de la salud
pública
o la reactivación económica en medio de
una situación macroeconómica que se
venía
visualizando como problemática no desde
hace cuatro años no en el último este
quinquenio sino desde hace por lo menos
veinte años y estoy hablando del modelo
de estado y el modelo país que sobre la
economía no se ha logrado este concertar
en universo territorio y me parece que
ese es un campo en disputa llamaríamos
de esa manera en el que hoy los dos
también las personas candidatas
parecieran no terminar de ponerse de
acuerdo en el cómo a lo mejor sabemos
cómo la inmensa mayoría de las personas
candidatas son las ciudadanas cuáles son
las posibles vías pero esas vías suponen
también implicación que algunos sectores
grupos de poder económico grupos de
poderosos desde el futbolista gremial
por ejemplo y su organización y
capacidad movilización que son
finalmente los poderes fácticos que
operan detrás de las candidaturas que no
han querido la verdad es que no han
tenido la voluntad siguiendo esa
aparente tradición civilista y
democrática que ha tenido nuestro país a
lo largo de 70 años no han querido
llegar a ese rumbo y han preferido que
sea la ciudadanía quien arbitre en un
sistema político que no se está
caracterizando repito desde hace al
menos diez años por un proceso de toma
de decisiones concertado sino por todo
lo contrario por el veto mutuo la
descalificación mutua y las campañas lo
podemos ver ahora con mayor detalle en
este momento están apuntando
lamentablemente hacia esa
descalificación más que el análisis
serio de las propuestas en ya su opinión
si coincido claramente con lo planteado
por el colega rod salt y agregaría que
la pandemia no necesariamente ha sido un
tema también por el importante pollo que
superior a un 60% según las últimas
encuestas de la universidad de costa
rica a las medidas que en algún momento
se tomaron para gestionarla y también a
la vacunación obligatoria que ha
alcanzado importantes porcentajes de la
población
han habido otros temas centrales el tema
económico por supuesto es sin embargo
dejando de lado una gran cuestión que va
a tener que llegar a gestionar el
próximo gobierno que es la agenda de
negociación con el fondo monetario
internacional para la facilitación de
recursos al país la temática de la
corrupción tanto desde el enfoque de
sanción como en el de prevención
respecto sobre todo a la corrupción en
la gestión de los asuntos públicos y
como se ha utilizado también esta
temática para golpear a ciertas
candidaturas y la discusión sobre el
tema educativo santiago que en esto ha
sido bastante laxa pero es una
preocupación común
es la relacionada con cómo resolver dos
años hasta tres años sistemáticos de
importantes limitaciones o problemas que
ha presentado en la situación educativa
del país a raíz de huelgas de gremio de
docentes posteriormente la gestión de la
pandemia que cerró las las escuelas y
los colegios y como esto nos va a cobrar
una factura un poco más tarde y es algo
en el que en lo que coinciden las
candidaturas no necesariamente en el
cómo pero sí como una preocupación y un
tema central en la campaña fuera de esos
temas que dan el tema ambiental y la
gestión del acuerdo de escazú temas
relacionados con seguridad y
narcotráfico transporte público y un
poquito muy superficialmente la
discusión sobre la pobreza
voy a profundizar más adelante en el
tema medioambiental a mí me llama la
atención el tema de los impuestos que
precisamente se lo han criticado mucho
al presidente actual al presidente
saliente que tuvo que poner una carga
impositiva mayor a los ciudadanos
precisamente por esa negociación que
tuvo con el fondo monetario
internacional para recibir un préstamo y
este tema pasó a volverse también un
punto de discrepancia con los ciudadanos
y con los candidatos unos lo ven como
necesario hay ustedes ya lo decían
algunos han dicho no más impuestos no no
necesitamos más impuestos no le vamos a
poner más cargas impositivas a los
ciudadanos precisamente para reactivar
la economía pero entonces como financiar
la capacidad del estado que ya usted lo
dicen es un estado que necesita ser más
eficiente para pagar esos préstamos y
esos compromisos internacionales eugenia
si sobre este tema es importante
puntualizar que cualquier candidato o
candidata que manifieste que está en
contra de imponer nuevos impuestos o
modificarlos para aumentar la carga
impositiva
necesariamente va a tener que revisar la
negociación ya ejecutada con el fondo
monetario internacional- en la
administración actual dado que la agenda
de compromisos negociados para mejorar
los ingresos y la gestión pública de
costa rica incluye la revisión del
impuesto a lo que se llama las casas de
lujo el impuesto solidario de la
vivienda implica también la revisión de
el impuesto a la renta y otro tipo de
medidas que
necesariamente van a tener que llevarse
a la mesa de discusión con el fondo por
otra parte hay quienes han sido más
moderados respecto a esta posición pero
definitivamente en la en la línea de
oponerse a cualquier tipo de impuesto
implicará una negociación con el fondo
por otro lado tenemos candidatos y
candidatas algunos entre las tendencias
más importantes de intención de voto que
han manifestado la eliminación de
impuestos y no han explicado mucho más
allá como es cuál sería la consecuencia
en términos de financiamiento y
equilibrio fiscal
rosell para cerrar este tema de los
impuestos necesarios imponer necesarios
dejarlos como están para que los
ciudadanos puedan tener un respiro en su
parte económica
perspectiva suya sobre este tema
me parece que ese es el tema y no de
cara a los próximos cuatro años sino que
lo ha venido siendo desde hace al menos
ocho años recordemos que en el año 2018
recién iniciando la período
constitucional el actual presidente
carlos alvarado tomó una decisión a mi
juicio atrevida pero arriesgada pero que
tuvo una buena lectura de la coyuntura
electo de la coyuntura de los partidos
políticos de la asamblea legislativa
cuando se aprobó la llamada reforma
imposible hasta ese momento que se venía
discutiendo de hace 20 años y fue la
reforma fiscal del año 2018 finales del
2018 que no fue pacífica su aprobación
por lo menos en las calles por lo menos
en el sentir de la mayoría de las
ciudadanas a este país no de una huelga
o mantuvo una huelga del sector público
principalmente durante 90 días y eso
pareciera que lo hemos olvidado ya se
logró aprobar esa reforma que muchos
sectores sociales sobre todo en
movimientos sociales califican como la
reforma más regresiva que ha tenido este
país y me parece tienen sustento
suficiente como para confirmar esa
percepción al darnos cuenta que hasta la
fecha la famosa reforma estructural
desde el punto de vista tributario
fiscal no ha generado los resultados que
se querían por el arbitrario agudizó el
debate entre en efecto si era necesario
volver a ver la estructura tributaria
actual y proponer otra reforma o también
a mi juicio como se han decantado la
mayoría de las personas candidatas no
apuntando hacia los ingresos sino
apuntando hacia los gastos y entonces
tiene como tema colateral y pareciera
una gran consenso desde el punto de
vista de la derecha por ejemplo el país
para no atender de manera inmediata a
los pepitos de estructura de los
ingresos clara no la de los gastos el
tamaño del estado y fundamentalmente las
leyes de deseo público y de crecimiento
el sector tumba pasó a preguntarle a
cindy regidor nuestra corresponsal hay
en san jose sobre este tema
medioambiental una prioridad para este
país siempre lo ha sido ha sido
destacado a nivel internacional con los
diferentes planes programas liderazgo
que ejerce costa rica
este tema y qué pasa ahora para estas
campañas siento y porque se bajó un poco
el acelerador en este tema
medioambiental entendemos que hay más
prioridades pero esto es una
característica del país es abanderado y
está en el adn de costa rica
lo que veo santiago es que si hay
preocupación pero de un sector
específico a lo mejor está también
dentro de ese sector específico la
población joven que tiene más presente
ese tema dentro de los principales para
tomar su decisión sobre por quién votar
y en esos sectores lo que mucho se
discute es uno que varios candidatos
pues dicen que no hay necesidad de
firmar el acuerdo de escazú y por otro
lado también les parece reprochable que
haya personas que estén hablando digamos
de revivir la pesca de arrastre o por
ejemplo la discusión sobre la
prohibición para explotar o explorar la
posibilidad de explotar petróleo en el
país es una ley una una iniciativa que
varios sectores han estado impulsando
que todavía pues no se ha logrado
concretar sin embargo eso es
definitivamente no es un tema de
conversación muy común en el caso
digamos del acuerdo de escazú lo que
dicen los candidatos algunos de ellos es
que en costa rica ya ha hecho suficiente
y hace más de lo que está plasmado en
ese acuerdo de escazú y que entonces no
hay necesidad de firmarlo pero y estos
sectores que están preocupados por que
realmente puedan seguir todas estas
políticas que a nivel mundial también se
están siguiendo en generar rápidamente
el tema ambiental antes de dar paso al
voto de las mujeres y el voto de los
jóvenes quiero conocer su opinión en
torno a este tema
la opinión sería que lamentablemente no
ha sido un tema de discusión más allá de
dos elementos la exploración de petróleo
y la explotación de gas natural como una
posibilidad que el estado costarricense
se comprometa tras muchísimos años de
ejercer moratoria sobre estas temáticas
ha sido una decisión de los poderes
ejecutivos plantear moratorias
normativas a la exploración y la
explotación de gas natural petróleo y el
cuestionamiento a las y los candidatos
hoy es si están dispuestos a
continuar esta moratoria que ha
mantenido en la temática ambiental
protegida en esa línea por otro lado del
acuerdo de escazú una decisión que
puedes competencia del poder legislativo
la ratificación de costa rica- del
acuerdo de escazú tampoco se ha
profundizado en los pormenores sin
embargo quienes se han opuesto a la
ratificación se han sustentado en los
planteamientos realizados por la sala
constitucional recuperando
la inversión de la carga de la prueba en
los procesos judiciales y en el marco de
lo ambiental requieren ya pocos minutos
para terminar el programa quiero pasar a
preguntarle a rocha y sobre el tema del
voto femenino importante destacado allí
en costa rica y también el voto de los
jóvenes porque precisamente hay una alta
tasa de desempleo entre los jóvenes
costarricenses y eso preocupa también a
la sociedad su opinión en torno a este
tema importante pueden ser fundamentales
en los jóvenes para definir a este
presidente el enfoque del candidato que
pueda pasar a esa segunda vuelta y que
eventualmente pueda llegar a la
presidencia cuál es su opinión rosa yo
dos observaciones al respecto ya bien
dijo siguiente al inicio del programa
que también el perfil de indecisión
mayoritario está concentrado en ese
segmento etario de 18 a 43 años
básicamente y también en esa condición
de las mujeres pero también hay que
hilar muy fino para saber hacia dónde se
podrían decantar finalmente ese gran
grupo de indecisos también parece que
hay que observar otra variable que es el
nivel educativo y el lugar de residencia
porque ciertamente pareciera que se está
subestimando esas dos variables y se
están robando en las categorías de sexo
y de condición etaria o de edad la
última decisión que parece que eso no va
a ser así que habrá que fijarse y las
las estrategias de campaña hoy deberían
estar concentradas en eso en saber
segmentar aún más fino y llegarle con el
discurso que dependiendo si es ciudad o
si es fuera del baño central o en las
costas la gente está necesitando
escuchar son distintas las condiciones
de empleo son distintas las condiciones
de crecimiento perspectivas económicas
en el acceso a la educación y a la salud
como servicios que siempre el
costarricense considera indispensable
para tomar una decisión con respecto al
voto de modo que en efecto el grupo
etario y de sexo más importante que va a
tener las elecciones y también el perfil
de indecisos que coincide con eso van a
ser las mujeres y los jóvenes pero van a
entrar otras variables como a nivel
educativo y en lugar de residentes
eugenia veo que siente lo que dice rosa
y cuál es su opinión
agregaría que en la tradición
democrática de costa rica pese a que
sólo hace 70 años se le otorgó el voto
femenino a las mujeres
son las mujeres las mayores agentes de
movilización del voto según los últimos
estudios que se han realizado de la
universidad de costa rica es desde el
género que desde el género femenino las
mujeres las abuelas las mamás que se
implanta la cultura democrática de
asistencia a las urnas y tiene enorme
influencia sobre el voto de sus parejas
y sus familiares respecto a la decisión
que se va a tomar el domingo 6 de
febrero es interesante sin embargo
también que en materia de género hay un
candidato que es ampliamente cuestionado
por una demanda ante el fondo en el
banco mundial en un trabajo anterior que
tuvo conductas
relacionados con acoso sexual y esto sin
embargo empecé que ha sido una temática
que le ha significado cierta afectación
al candidato a la candidata no no se ha
trasladado en una discusión generalizada
sobre las problemáticas de las mujeres
ni tampoco sobre la la violencia que se
está viviendo hacia las mujeres ancianas
sobre partes del país entonces va a ser
un voto decisivo pero también es un voto
que hoy por hoy no tiene respuestas del
infierno y sus candidatos en contienda
rápidamente mercado minuto para
finalizar el programa conclusiones cindy
que podemos esperar el domingo entonces
rápidamente unos segundos por favor
una total sorpresa a santiago
definitivamente no se sabe quién podrá
pasar a la segunda ronda todo podría
pasar sobre todo entre los candidatos
que están punteando en intención de
votos pero que casi que tienen un empate
técnico entre sí y algo importante
destacar es que en el país hay mucha
estabilidad en cuanto a que el resultado
que dé el tribunal supremo de elecciones
va a ser un resultado en el que todos
pueden confiar rápidamente rocha y su
opinión de conclusión
tiene una enorme incertidumbre por lo
tanto el elemento sorpresa va a ser el
más distintivo de ese día
y es subrayó lo que acaba de decir
siendo a pesar de la disputa a pesar de
la incertidumbre de los resultados hasta
altas horas de la noche el próximo
domingo se no obstante considera que
sigue siendo blindado y legitimado la
organización electoral encabezada por el
tribunal supremo que se me acaba el
tiempo eugenia a su se me acaba el
tiempo que a debiéndonos su conclusión
para el cierre del programa les
agradezco por haber estado con nosotros
a ustedes muchas gracias por haber
estado en audi en sintonía con france24
y siga con nosotros
[Música]